o
[Música]
Olá Todos Eu sou Luiz Felipe adaime e
venho com uma mensagem de urgência para
todos vocês e para humanidade começa a
conseguir te passo
e nesses últimos cinco segundos ou cinco
bater de Palmas que eu fiz a gente
perdeu cinco hectares de Floresta pelo
mundo a gente tá perdendo
florestas tropicais especialmente a
floresta amazônica
em No Ritmo extremamente alarmante a
isso combinado corro o nosso vício né da
nossa sociedade capitalista
a
moderna a por combustíveis fósseis tem
levado a uma elevação
absurda a dos níveis de gases de efeito
estufa e ao maior desafio é o argumento
a maior desafio que a humanidade já teve
a sua história que é baixar os níveis de
emissões por mais da metade até 2030
2030 suava como o mar e distante hoje em
dia já uma data bastante próxima daqui a
oito anos e pouquinho
nós temos que reduzir o atual nível de
emissões de 55 milhões de toneladas
e para 25 bilhões de toneladas até 2030
para dar uma referência do que que esse
número de 55 milhões de toneladas
seria são 55 bilhões de balões igual um
balão precisa Turquia da Capadócia uma
bola do tamanho da lua de gás de efeito
estufa na de gás carbônico que a gente
está soltando para atmosfera a cada sete
anos é uma enormidade de poluição e esse
né esse número esse nível de emissão de
gases de efeito estufa
aumentou drasticamente era de 25 bilhões
12 anos atrás então era de 25 b200 atrás
subiu para o atual nível de 55 milhões a
gente tem que reduzir a 25 bilhões nos
próximos anos se não fizermos isso o que
que acontece com o mundo É um cenário de
catástrofe completo é a e os primeiros
sinais disso de mudança climática mais
drásticas estamos começando a ver com as
enchentes que e na Alemanha o incêndio
que acontece na Califórnia na Austrália
na seca a incêndios no Pantanal que é
uma área extremamente úmida e chuvosa e
se não fizermos nada daqui a 50 anos eu
tenho uma filha de dois anos quando o
livro estiver
52 anos
é basicamente ela vai morar no mundo
onde todas as cidades litorâneas Onde
está debaixo d'água como probabilidade
de mais de cinquenta por cento Então
esquece Rio de Janeiro esquece maior Não
esquece Nova York onde a todas a as
áreas Tropicais do mundo né América
Latina EA África Sudeste Asiático vou
está inabitáveis por que vão está muito
quente mesmo em temperaturas a sombra
estamos falando de temperatura sair de
60 a 65 graus ou seja o mundo vai ter né
Dois Bilhões de pessoas a mais vamos
crescer de 8 milhões de pessoas para 10
milhões de pessoas esses dois bilhões de
pessoas há mais ou as pessoas vão ter
que morar ou no extremo norte do planeta
no extremo sul a e finalmente o problema
maior problema mais grave maior desafio
que a queda de produção de comida né
todas as cercas a impactam especialmente
os pobres populações
em casa da linha de miséria que tem
agricultura de subsistência a tempo por
exemplo regiões da África onde já tem
seca há mais de 4 anos e
tons estão sofrendo cada vez mais quando
problema da Fome isso tente essa gravar
bastante para o problema de mudanças
climáticas Como resolvemos
nós temos que aumentar muito o nível de
compensação das nossas emissões que quer
dizer isso é qual é a melhor solução
para emissão É lógico que é zerar aí me
só né a gente ir d-55b para 0 Mas isso é
um cenário não faz sentir assim a gente
vai ter bastante dificuldade mesmo para
reduzir pela metade como a gente
incentivar cria um Cusco para a
sociedade para as empresas aquelas
reduzam as suas emissões o mais
rapidamente possível mas eficientemente
possível a gente atribui um custo elas e
é assim que funciona o crédito de Acabou
o crédito de carbono
ao contrário do que a gente pensa é um
certificado digital no sentido mais alto
de
auditar e comprovar atividade de uma
empresa ou de um projeto ambiental que
através de sua atividade o editor missão
de gaja fixo então a não é um pé de
carbono não é necessariamente plantar
uma árvore ou plantar uma floresta né
fazer reflorestamento ou não é
necessariamente uma a captura de CO2 do
ar maquininha dessas de captura de
carbono igual ela umas a argumento mas
sim um sentido Mais amplo
de
incentivar remunerará empresas através
da emissão e venda de créditos de
carbono para empresas poluidoras
e aquelas evitem e missões então exemplo
aqui mais claro mas tangível é um parque
eólico um parque solar agitado que gera
crédito ficar boa né No entanto a gente
também sabe aquele parque solar um monte
de painel solar aquilo tira são dois lá
então por que que gera crédito de
carbono porque aquele parque solar
digamos de 1 megawatt de potência
evitou a construção de uma térmica
acabou que queimaria casam para gerar
energia para vão ser do combustível faço
o dizer né É para gerar energia e emitir
a poluição quando você citou essa por só
você já era esse certificados digitais
que vocês chamam mal né chama-se uma
auditoria uma editora global ou prova
aquilo e as grandes empresas do mundo
compromisso porque as empresas do mundo
tão comprando isso
Esse é o primeiro porque o mundo as
grandes economias do mundo o Brasil não
é regulado mas as grandes economias do
mundo já são regular ou seja o governo
estabelece um regulador que possa o que
estabelece o limite também né e posta
com que empresas Tipo nem assim quando
esse limite compra e créditos de carbono
de empresas que poluem abaixo desse
limite aí você cria um incentivo do
criasse um incentivo duplo no quadro o
capital né os recursos a grana fui tipo
é a mais aqui pula mesmo é o caso da
Tesa né a Tesla sabemos que tem custo
usar pela sua expansão que ela não tem
lucro mas ela teve um lucro de 400
Milhões de Dólares no passado como que
foi isso é ela sentiu o trabalho né de
de evitar emissões através da fabricação
de carro elétrico a e Ford Volkswagen
tem as outras empresas do setor que
produzem carro a combustão se tiver que
comprar créditos de carbono da terra
Então é assim que funciona na Califórnia
no na costa leste americana províncias
canadenses Europa Austrália Japão Coreia
entre as maiores economias do mundo esse
ano Latino
a setenta por cento do PIB Global já é
regulado de alguma maneira isso reflete
99%
12 milhões de toneladas ou créditos de
carbono são intercambiáveis dos 12
milhões de toneladas que é o Mercado
Global de festa de calor mercado enorme
500 Bilhões de Dólares ao ano né Mais ou
menos um terço do PIB brasileiro para
dar uma referência é
paralelo a isso a o mercado
verdadeiramente Global porque
uma empresa californiana não pode
comprar créditos de carbono na China por
que tá mais barato na China e vice-versa
então esses mercados ainda não se
conversam mas tem um mercado
verdadeiramente Global cuja oferta cujo
fornecimento bem realmente de projetos
ambientais que o mercado voluntário
e na E aí é o mercado de 100 milhões de
toneladas ao ano não preço médio de 7
dólares de Campos de 700 milhões de
dólares ou seja menos um por cento do
mercado Total mas é o mercado de
crescimento explosivo a e oferta Talita
vidro de grandes florestas nas grandes
projetos de conservação de florestas em
áreas de 100 a 150 mil unidades para dar
uma referência à cidade de São Paulo tem
150 mil hectares ou seja são áreas né do
tamanho de uma grande metrópole ou
Grandes projetos de energia limpa né
hidrelétricas energia renovável no geral
eólica solar teto E aí elas provam Como
disse que evitar a emissão e emitem
certificados chamados créditos de
carbono no mercado voluntário Quem
compra esses créditos
empresas que não estão sendo entre
"obrigadas pelos seus reguladores nesses
mercados regulados mencionei mas estão
sim sendo cada vez mais obrigadas pelo
e pela demanda pela sua demanda tanto de
investidores como de consumidores
aconteceu teve um evento três ou quatro
anos atrás que pouca gente né motor
apareceu um pouco da mídia que foi que
os milénios né que o grupo de pessoas
que nasceram depois de 980 seja pessoas
de até 40 41 anos
que esse grupo passou de Baby boomers
que a geração e tem hoje em dia 60 70 80
anos é isso muda
mudou todos os valores e comportamento
de demanda de investidores de
consumidores do mundo não é à toa que a
cide e questões sustentáveis tanto
investimento comicon somos vieram à tona
e e parece uma modinha mas é algo
extremamente estrutural é demanda dessas
pessoas mais jovens que quando ela sim
descem comprou ações os papéis do
investe em o que essas empresas a emitir
vem andando para fazer meio ambiente ou
evitem do nome ambiente e fluxo para
fundo Iraci ditados o tablet todinho
aumentou de Seis Milhões de Dólares 2
anos atrás para 60 Milhões de Dólares
estimados esse ano a e grandes empresas
de consumo Unilever Dawson Johnson like
é por todas as maiores empresas de
consumo do mundo ocidental e cada vez
mais do mundo oriental a estão
anunciando Nilton prédios e são
compromissos de natalidade de carbono
até uma certa data normalmente até 2030
porque é o nosso maior desafio não
consigo expressar e suficiente a e vai
ser um a solução vai se dar por um
esforço coletivo de todos nós pagarmos
um dois por cento de tudo que a gente
gasta para mitigação e compensação das
nossas emissões muito bom
G1